Neymark 정리의 맥락에서 다뤘던 이 측정의 구현을 고려해서 비파괴적 측정으로 바꿀 수 있어요.
새로운 시스템 Y를 도입하고, 유니터리 연산 U를 통해 X와 상호작용시킨 다음, Y에 표준
기저 측정을 수행해요. 그러면 시스템 X가 여전히 남아 있고, 그 상태를 고려할 수 있어요.
앞서 한 분석을 바탕으로, 특정 측정 결과 a를 얻었을 때 X의 측정 후 상태가
이렇게 생긴 밀도 행렬로 주어진다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
말로 하면, 해당 측정 행렬의 제곱근으로 켤레를 취하고 그 다음
정규화해요. 비파괴적 측정을 공식화하는 또 다른 방법은 더 일반적인 건데, 채널의 Kraus
행렬로 표현하는 거예요. 이게 Nielsen과 Chuang의 유명한 교과서에서 찾을 수 있는 측정의 정의예요.
예를 들어, M0부터 Mm-1까지가 화면에 표시된 방정식을 만족하는 정사각 행렬들이라고 해요.
즉 이 행렬들을 채널을 표현하는 Kraus 행렬로 생각할 수 있다는 거예요.
실제로 이 행렬들은 채널을 표현하지만, 비파괴적 측정도 표현해요.
주어진 상태 ρ의 시스템이 측정될 때 어떻게 작동하는지는, 먼저 결과 확률이
화면에 표시된 방정식으로 주어져요. 각 결과는 Ma × ρ × Ma 대거의 트레이스와 같은 확률로 나타나요.
그리고 결과 a가 나타났을 때, 측정된 시스템의 상태는 이렇게 돼요.
이런 종류의 비파괴적 측정은 Neymark 정리에서 했던 것과 비슷하게 구현될 수 있어요.
원한다면 직접 생각해보세요. 비파괴적 측정의 개념을 이것보다 더 일반화하는 것도 가능해요.
예를 들어, 양자 기계라고 불리는 개념이 때로 꽤 유용하지만, 이 영상에서는 다루지
않을 거예요. 강의 마지막 부분에서는 측정과 관련된 두 가지 과제에 대해 간략하게 다룰 거예요. 양자 상태 판별과 양자 상태
단층 촬영이에요. 두 개념 모두에 대해 할 말이 꽤 많은데, 정말 표면적인 부분만 다룰 거예요.
그러면 이 용어들이 무엇을 의미하고 어떻게 다른지 명확히 해보는 것부터 시작할게요.
첫 번째는 양자 상태 판별이에요. 여기서 아이디어는 어떤 시스템의 알려진 양자 상태들의 모음과
이 상태들과 관련된 확률들을 가지고 있다는 거예요.
정확히 말하면, ρ0부터 ρM-1까지가 시스템 X의 가능한 양자 상태들을 나타내는 밀도 행렬들이고,
p0부터 pN-1까지가 이 상태들과 관련된 확률들이라고 해요. 확률들을 하나의
벡터로 모으면 확률 벡터를 얻어요. 이걸 간단히 말하면 양자
상태들의 앙상블을 가지고 있다는 거예요. 이제 양자 상태 판별을 과제 또는 문제로 추상적으로 생각해볼 수 있어요.
먼저 0과 N-1 사이의 숫자가 확률에 따라 무작위로 선택돼요. 그 다음 시스템 X가
무작위로 선택된 숫자에 해당하는 상태로 준비돼요. 목표는 X를 측정해서
어떤 숫자가 선택되었는지 알아내는 거예요.
그래서 사전 확률과 함께 유한한 수의 대안이 있고, 목표는 실제로 어떤 대안이 발생했는지 알아내는 거예요.
일부 상태와 확률 선택에 대해서는 이게 쉬울 수 있고, 다른 경우에는 오류 가능성 없이 하는 게 불가능할 수 있어요.
그리고 물어볼 수 있는 다양한 구체적인 질문들이 있어요. 예를 들면 오류를 낼 최소 확률은 뭔지,
이 최소 오류 확률을 달성하는 측정은 어떻게 생겼는지 같은 거예요.
반면 양자 상태 단층 촬영은 달라요. 여기서는 시스템의 알려지지 않은 양자 상태를 가지고 있어요.
그래서 보통 사전 확률이나 가능한 대안에 대한 어떤 정보도 없어요.
하지만 이번엔 상태의 단 하나의 사본이 아니라 많은 독립적인 사본들이 주어져요.
즉 어떤 큰 수 n에 대해 각각 독립적으로 상태 ρ로 준비된
n개의 동일한 시스템 X1부터 Xn까지가 있다는 거예요. 이번의 목표는 시스템들을 측정해서
이 알려지지 않은 양자 상태의 근사치를 밀도 행렬로 찾는 거예요.
요약하면, 양자 상태 판별에서는 상태의 단 하나의 사본을 가지고
유한한 수의 알려진 대안들 중에서 판별하려 해요. 양자 상태 단층 촬영에서는 알려지지 않은 양자 상태의 많은 독립적인
사본들을 가지고 있고, 목표는 그 상태에 대한 설명이나 적어도 괜찮은 근사치를 찾는 거예요.
양자 상태 판별은 흥미로운데, 계산이나 암호학 같은 분야에서 흔히 나타나는 상황 유형을 추상화하기 때문이에요.
유한한 가능성 집합 중 하나의 대안이 발생했고, 우리나 다른 누군가가 양자 시스템을 측정해서 어떤 게 발생했는지 알아내려 하는 경우에요.
가장 단순한 비자명한 경우는 딱 두 가지 대안이 있는 경우인데, M이 2와 같아요. 그러면 과제는 한 쌍의
상태들 사이에서 판별하는 거예요. 이 경우는 본질적으로 완전히 해결된 문제예요. 목표가 잘못된 판별 확률을 최소화하는 것이라면요.
측정에 대한 최적의 선택이 있는데, 종종
Helstrom 측정이라고 불려요. 사실 사영 측정이고,
다음과 같이 표현할 수 있어요. 먼저 두 대안 사이의 가중 차이를 고려해요.
즉 p0 × ρ0 빼기 p1 × ρ1이에요. 두 상태 각각을 뽑을 확률을 상태 자체에 곱하고
차를 구하는 거예요. 이건 자기 켤레 전치와 같으니까 에르미트 행렬이에요.
그래서 스펙트럼 분해가 있고, 고유값이 모두 실수라는 걸 알 수 있어요. 그러면 화면에 표시된
형태로 쓰인 스펙트럼 분해가 있다고 가정할게요. 다음에 할 일은
고유값들을 두 집합으로 모으는 거예요. 모든 양의 고유값은 한 집합에, 모든 음의 고유값은
다른 집합에 넣어요. 정확히 말하면, S0을 해당 고유값 λk가
음이 아닌 모든 인덱스 k의 집합으로 하고, S1은 나머지 인덱스들, 즉 음의 고유값에 해당하는 것들로 해요.
여기서 0인 고유값들에 해당하는 인덱스들을 어느 집합에 넣는지는 실제로 중요하지 않아요.
여기서는 임의로 0인 것들을 S0에 포함시키지만, 일부 또는 전부가 S1에 포함되어도 아무 차이가 없어요.
정말 중요한 건 양의 고유값과 음의 고유값을 분리한다는 거예요. 마지막으로 두 사영 Pi
0과 Pi 1을 화면에 표시된 것처럼 정의해요. 말로 하면, Pi 0은
양의 고유값과 영인 고유값에 해당하는 고유 벡터들로 이루어진 부분 공간으로의 사영이에요.